- We're gonna cover a topic
that's often neglected in
observability, actually.
So I want you to imagine
as we go through this talk,
this is a relatively
straightforward case study.
You guys hear me okay?
Oh, that's so many
thumbs up. This is great.
Okay. There's positivity.
So one of the things that
really comes up very commonly is
organizations talk about
things like observability being
very, very expensive.
They also talk about things
like the value being unclear,
super interesting industry
because often there is a
budget for observability.
It's fundamentally really important.
It's very difficult to
operate the software
that drives our businesses and
our bottom line without it.
So we know how essential it is
and yet we still feel
it's very, very expensive.
The theory here, and I think
it's it bears true over
and over again, is that actually
it's not really about it
being too high a price.
It's that the value is unclear.
And so what this talk
is kind of an example,
taking probably some of
the most unstructured
like simple data that we can take
and apply a few different
transformations in enrichments.
And we end up with something
that can be carried all the way
to our C-suite and we can
tell 'em about it, a message
that can be carried
across the entire company.
And that is a fundamental
component of business growth.
We'll talk about how information
flows through a company.
We'll talk about the
importance of technical events
and what they actually mean
across the entire company.
And once again, I'm
talking about very simple
data here for a reason.
This is what you can do
with even the simplest
data in a few lookup tables.
You can imagine what can be
achieved when you have full APM,
traces, logs, metrics.
When you can correlate
those things together,
you can tell a much, much richer story.
So quickly about Coralogix,
we launched 2017.
The platform has grown massively.
I've been at Coralogix
for about four years
and in that time we gained
thousands of thousands of customers.
Big thing, eight high availability
regions including GovCloud.
And we are FedRAMP ready.
So we are gonna go fully
approved mid next year.
So we're going through
that process right now.
The high availability regions mean
that we have multiple
deployments in these regions
and that includes if you
have a European presence
and you have GDPR requirements.
For example, we have European
places, we have East coast
and West coast deployments in the US
and as I mentioned, GovCloud as well.
Super important of course, these days,
data residency regulations
are becoming tighter.
So yeah, and, you know,
raised a great deal of money
in funding and now we're moving
to the stage where we scale
and we start to think more
deeply about what the customers need.
This slide we bring out a lot
and it's super, super interesting.
So one of the things that I
think really sets us apart
as a company is the platform
is awesome, but the support
and services are really next level.
This is most aptly exemplified by this,
less than 30 second median response time.
That's no bots, no L1 engineers.
It's straight to a person whose
whole job is to figure out
what the problems are in observability
stacks and help you fix them.
But the engagement goes beyond that.
And this is kind of what a
part of this talk is about.
The engagement goes beyond
just problem resolution.
It's what are your goals
and how can we move you
towards achieving them.
Less than one hour median resolve time.
To give you an idea, the next fastest
response time is about three hours.
So a median response, our
resolve time right now is faster
than the response to MSLA
of our closest competitor.
And there's no tiering
in the solution either.
So there's no enterprise packages
or anything like that,
that's just charged by gigabyte ingested.
If you ingest one gigabyte, you get this.
This is something we've scaled
and that some of you have gone, hmm?
And the reason why is
because you wonder how we've got scale,
how are we gonna scale that kind of thing?
When I first started at Coralogix four
years ago, we had about, I think about
2,000 customers, just under.
And we used to advertise a five
minute median response time.
Now it's over 4,000 customers
and we are less than 30
second median response.
We've actually got faster as we've scaled.
It's a big, big thing
with automation internally,
heavy documentation.
But we have 80 people in
our support organization
and we're a company of 600.
Ultimately one of the
things we identified was,
is a big problem in this industry
and that the supports does not match
the importance of the software.
So observability is
becoming like a core pillar
of how we run our businesses.
It's becoming a really important
part of how we operate and grow.
Not just our software but
our practices as teams.
Many of us will be
thinking about things like
service level objectives.
We'll be thinking about high
level table stakes metrics
to make sure that you can,
the teams can make autonomous
decisions within sensible
frameworks, all essential
for scale software engineering,
all powered by observability
and without the observability, very,
very difficult to achieve.
So that's the reason why
we offer this support
because it matches the
importance of the software,
matches the importance of the application.
And of course cost optimization support.
So we have some of the best
cost optimization tools in the market
and we can talk about those later.
And the migration times are crazy fast.
You can check the case
studies on the website,
but we have multiple like 24
to 48 hour turnaround times
for full stack logs, metrics
and traces from very large engagements.
That's largely powered by our
commitment to use OpenTelemetry.
OpenTelemetry beat.
We'll do a show of hands.
Everyone familiar with OpenTelemetry?
In this crowd,
I imagine it's gonna
be pretty, yeah, yeah.
So OpenTelemetry for the one
or two hands that didn't
go up is a collection
of software collectors.
So it's a collector that
actually captures the telemetry.
SDKs.
So it goes inside your code base
and it'll help you generate
the telemetry you need to generate.
Standards and protocols.
So standards and protocols
like the OTLP protocol,
which is the actual,
like the actual informational protocol
that communicates the
telemetry, logs, metrics
and traces profiles, security events
and so on up to an OTLP
compliant collector,
much like Coralogix, Coralogix
is fully OTel compatible.
In fact our APM and our
tracing is OTel native.
So there's no, some of the other vendors,
what they do is they say they use OTel,
but when you use it you lose a
bunch of features or something.
That's not us. You get full
feature coverage with OTel.
That's how we run that and it's
been very, very beneficial.
It means the migrations are
really easy If you're using TEL
today, it's typically a few lines
of config in your OTel config.
It's very, very easy.
Very briefly about myself,
I, my whole background is SRE
and software engineering basically.
When I told people I go
into software engineering,
they asked me if I can fix computers
and I didn't know how to
explain to them that most
of it is breaking computers
and it's great fun
and the, yeah.
And then I moved into
engineering leadership a lot.
Very, very large retailer in the UK.
I was responsible for a
hundred million dollars
of cloud and on-premise infrastructure.
And my job was to try to
coalesce around tools,
especially hosting and
observability tools, helping,
I think it was two
and a half thousand
engineers across hundreds
of teams in I think every time zone.
Trying to get them all in the same
line was interesting.
And I realized at that point that
what I should be doing is evangelism,
'cause that was more
or less my job anyway.
So I tried a few different roles
and I landed at Coralogix four years ago.
And since then we've grown
the evangelism program.
We have people in the states,
in the UK, in Tel Aviv
where we are constantly going to customers
and just talking to them
and hanging out with them
and working out what their problems are
and saying, well what, you know, what's,
and it can be anything
from I can't get this
configuration to work.
This OTel configuration
isn't playing nicely for me,
or my teams just don't understand
service level objectives
and I'm struggling to
get 'em on board with it.
And we engage across that entire thing.
And I'll talk a bit about that
later with the maturity model
that we've made that helps
to contextualize that.
So the premise of this
talk is very simple.
There's a common, common
misconception in a company,
which is that there is the tech side
and then there's like the businessy side.
Hands if you've seen that before?
It's like, yeah,
like tech tech in a room somewhere
and business are off
doing businessy things.
And the problem with this
misconception is that it,
it's just not, well
fundamentally it's just not true anymore.
It maybe was true a long time
ago when tech was a niche part
of the company, but now it's a
horizontal enabler for everything.
Companies that have the best tech
compete better in the business.
It's all mixed together.
But the problem is, is that
many of the tools that we use
to measure and track
events, correlate instances
of things happening, still
operate with this in mind.
There's like a techie interface
and there's a businessy
interface and so on.
The problem is siloing of
information is really difficult.
It causes big problems.
You cannot correlate
across siloed information.
You can do it but with great difficulty
and a lot of manual work.
So getting everything to
one place very important.
And the problem with this
assumption fundamentally is this,
if you have a CTO, an
engineering director,
engineering manager and some
technical event has happened,
then it kind of goes up that track
and it only really makes its
way out if it's important,
significant enough, quote unquote.
But the definition of significant enough
is often not codified.
Marketing insights make
their way up to the CMO,
but they don't really go anywhere else.
And sales insights often make their way up
to the chief sales officer,
the chief revenue officer, and
they don't go anywhere else.
But I as an engineer might
be interested in the sales
insight 'cause it's
something a customer said,
it might actually be quite
interesting to know what,
we don't do our sales process this way
because the product doesn't facilitate it.
That's interesting. As an
engineer, I wouldn't know that.
I might have a marketing
insight, the drop off on pages,
the bounce rate on pages,
these are all things
that marketing teams tend to measure,
but they are technical measurements
that apply across the entire company.
And so how do we change
this flow of information?
So what we don't wanna do is
we don't wanna end up in a
situation like this where we kind
of rely on just ad hoc collaboration,
which is most companies
like vast, vast majority
of companies, why don't we wanna
rely on ad hoc collaboration?
It is basically, it's
based on the goodwill
and the friendship of a very,
typically a very small group of people.
For any of you who've, I'll
do a final show of hands.
This is my favorite thing to do.
Who's been in your company,
in your current employment,
one year or more?
Yeah. Two years or
more, keep the hands up.
Three years or more?
Four years or more?
Five?
We'll jump 10. Yeah.
Okay, thank you.
So if you've been in there 10 years
or more, you start to
pretty much know everybody
and you it, it stops becoming
about following processes
like, oh, I know, I know the person.
So that is an ad hoc
engagement and there's
nothing wrong with that.
It's great to have that
as a natural thing,
but it's not the bedrock.
The bedrock needs to be the flow
of information naturally
is making its way across.
And the way you do that
is by joined up tooling.
So you, you wanna avoid that.
You wanna try and get away from this.
And when we think about
software events, they,
these technical moments,
they impact everybody.
Okay, if I have an API
slow down, then it is going
to impact every single part
portion of that company
if you're a technical company.
Because if your API is slowing
down, your pages load slower,
your marketing, the landing page
that your marketing team just set up
may load slower as well.
There may be ripple effects
across your entire stack.
Really important.
So the really, really important thing
to recognize here is these
technical moments need
to be surfaced in a way
that's really significant.
Right now, they tend to go up
that technical track, right?
If I see a CPU spike, I get
told the CTO gets told about it,
but it doesn't make its way out
horizontally in a natural way.
It's not common anyway.
So how do we do something in practice?
That's all the high level stuff.
How do we actually take a very,
very low level simple signal
and turn it into something that
we can communicate upwards?
So lemme give you an example.
We have a log like
this, it's unstructured.
There's nothing particularly
remarkable about it.
This is kind of cool by the way.
This is like a log
summary thing that we do.
If anyone's using, anyone
using Coralogix today, yeah,
go to a log, hit space.
Yeah, this guy, it's really cool.
There's loads of Easter
eggs in the app like that
and this will like pull
out all the metadata
that's automatically recognized.
There's trace IDs in there
for trace correlation,
but the log itself is
not particularly useful.
If you took that and you said, Hey,
I have an RPC not found error
and you go to someone non-technical,
they're gonna be like,
what the hell are you talking about?
There's business context to this.
This happens during a a checkout process.
So every single time this
happens, someone tried
to buy something and they couldn't.
That's the business
context of this message.
Okay, so we, we can see
something interesting in there.
This ID on the end,
and this is something we
might wanna filter on.
So we can take that technical
signal and we can pass
and extract the really essential values,
the ones that really matter.
Why is that important?
It allows you to index the
fields that really matter.
And then you can do things
like query and filter
and you can aggregate on
various different things.
You can join and pivot and I
can show you how to do that.
And then you can enrich.
Enrichment is something
that I think I never see
and we do it a lot in
the Coralogix platform.
What is enrichment?
Enrichment is when you have some kind
of field and you say, okay,
but I have tons of metadata around this ID
and I wanna add the metadata into my log.
Now why do you wanna do that?
Because then you have a single
document with all the
context that you need,
that's really important
for like in-depth analysis.
And finally you can convert
that data into something useful.
And what I mean by something
useful, I mean something
that you can take and you
can take all the way up
to the C level and say, hey,
this is a significant
thing and here's why.
And they'll understand it.
And that's the flow of information working
in a less ad hoc way.
So you can begin by
creating a lookup table.
So in Coralogix we have this
idea called data sets. Okay?
Now a data set is a bit
like a table in a database.
It's a collection of similar data.
It doesn't have to be all
the same structure and shape,
but it's similar data.
It doesn't have to be time
series. So this is a lookup.
Now notice the ID on the left hand side
looks much like the ID we
saw in the previous log.
So, and we have a bunch of
product information here.
So what could we do with that?
Well this is a lookup table
with which we can enrich.
So what we can do is use our
language called DataPrime.
So DataPrime is an analytics
language that we use.
You can query logs, metrics
and traces in a single query.
It supports all the things
that you would expect
from something like SQL.
So joins and filters
and aggregations and counting and so on.
In this particular example,
what we do is we take
that custom data set product details
and we will join the original log on it.
And notice here, we've on the fly,
we've extracted the product
ID as a field onto itself.
So now we have a product
ID that's own field
and we say, Hey, join on that
and give me everything
from that lookup table
that's relevant to that ID.
And that turns the original thing into
something that's a bit more interesting.
So what I can do is that once
I know the price of the item
and I know it was a checkout
process that was failing,
I can start asking questions,
how much money are we
losing as a result of that?
Okay, so when you go to your boss
and you say, I have a not found OPC error,
that's tough to say.
If you go to your boss and
say, in the last 15 minutes we
just lost $1,500 due to this bug,
that's a compelling message.
That will take people's attention.
So this massaging and
preparation of data is really,
really important for a number of things.
Now I'll double click on them.
One, once you get your data into a more,
let's say organized shape,
I think one of the things
that we did in observability,
for a long time don't remember this.
This is an example if I,
the common pattern was,
and in in many places still
is I take some data, all
of it goes into sort of high
performance index storage,
open store, OpenSearch with a
SSD hard drives underneath it,
something like that.
And then after like two
weeks it goes into some sort
of low cost storage compressed.
If we ever wanna access it
again, we have to go back
to low cost storage and pull it back out.
And the, the assumption
of that is that all
of the data is equal 'cause it's all
being traced in the same way.
Which is not true.
Some logs only become useful
after a certain amount of time.
Some traces are only only useful
for 10 seconds when they happen.
So we have to treat data differently.
So what we can do here is that the really,
really fun edition is that
this is actually being queried
directly from S3 as well.
This is actually all held
in customer cloud S3,
which is a significant detail.
So that's really important
because now I have a business insight.
It's something that I can take to people,
I can communicate it to anybody
and it's really easy to do.
So why are we doing this?
Why am I stood up here
talking about business
insights as an SRE?
Because I've started
with a very simple log.
Now imagine what you can do
with things like a trace.
It's got a bunch of metadata
on there that you've added in.
And because we're using
an enrichment model,
we're not talking about going
and changing 500 applications
to make sure a correlation idea
is making its way in there.
What we're talking about
is taking the stuff
that's already in there and
saying, oh I can enrich on
that if this tag relates
to this particular server,
I can enrich based on that server.
If it's based in a certain
region or a department
or any metadata that exists,
I can enrich on those fields.
So the enrichment model amplifies
the fields that are already there.
And if you want, you
can add more at source.
And the reason why I'm
talking about this is
because we've built this thing,
it's the observability maturity model.
It's broken down to four different levels.
There's something really
significant about this.
We are bringing this to every
single one of our customers.
It is a north star vision for
how observability is moving forward.
Level one is essentially
telemetry coverage.
It's getting a stack of full
stack telemetry, so logs,
metrics, traces, profiles,
events and so on.
It's basically just getting coverage
for this stuff you've already got.
Why is that level one?
It's very, very difficult
to progress in this with
massive gaps in your data.
And a big problem today,
especially with a lot
of the vendors, is that
people make these massive cost
optimizations by not
sending logs for example,
which is tough.
It makes causal analysis
very, very difficult.
So avoiding those gaps is
really, really important.
The next level is
engineering intelligence.
And this is where most of us
get to and what we describe one
and two is like a generic problem.
So engineering intelligence
is things like you have a
telemetry, you coalesce
it around your databases
or your infrastructure or your servers
or the processes running
on your servers and so on.
Super important because this is the,
almost the gold standard for
SRE today is defining SLOs,
consistent measurements across
teams, that kind of thing.
This is where, there are observability
maturity models out there today
and they all stop here.
And one of the things
that we realized was
there is this big problem
that I mentioned at the
start of this talk, which is
that the feeling is
we're not getting enough
value outta this data.
The feeling is is that we're not getting
the return that we expected.
How do we maximize the return
that we can possibly get
as engineers, but also as
people working in a business?
How do we connect these
deeply technical signals
to business growth and to
business impacting measurements?
What we do is we start,
start to say things like,
well let's take all that
engineering knowledge
and put it into a production context.
Production context means rather
than just saying my API has
breached my 500 millisecond SLO,
it's what was the customer impact of that?
And those, that's where
things like APM become really,
really useful 'cause you can actually
measure the thing over time.
But DataPrime and I showed you before,
allows you to crunch all that
data in new and custom ways.
The necessity of a really flexible,
really rich query language is fundamental
to the whole process.
It's very difficult to get
this done without that.
And the the second thing
that's really, really important
as you're moving into the later parts
of the maturity model is
you have to have access
to a significant portion of your data.
Without it, it's really, really difficult.
If you, for example, as many
of the customers I've spoken
to do, they don't produce
traces, it's just too expensive
or it's just not scaling
for them or whatever.
We can have a really,
really good go at this,
but it's hard because the
traces give you a really good
visibility of how the different
services are talking with one another.
They have help you identify
bottlenecks and performance issues.
Root cause analysis is really
a lot easier with traces,
much like without logs by the way.
There's a lot of talk now about removing
logs entirely from the whole thing.
I understand that, I think logs are
great for causal analysis.
Having just metrics for example,
you can tell you what's happening.
There's a CPU spike, it's very difficult
to understand the why and
logs often have the context
for the why but that, so having
that data in the first
place is really important.
That's why it's level
one. Without major gaps.
So we've taken our engineering knowledge,
we've put it into production context
and we're saying things
like, rather than just SLOs,
what does this mean to the
customer relationships?
How have we breached our SLAs?
And that's really, it's so useful.
You know, you can imagine
a VP of engineering
or a sort of CCTO level who's
getting pressure about these
things can go to a dashboard
and analyze that directly.
It's not some derived
calculation or something
they're told about.
One of the practices that some
of our customers have started
doing, which I love, is they
have started to define SLOs
and then SLAs in the same dashboard
and they've defined their
SLOs as a little bit
of a padding between their SLAs.
And so the SLOs become a leading indicator
for breaching their SLAs.
Super cool.
And that's a really, really nice example
of applying this kind of logic.
So reproduction intelligence.
There is the level four.
Now one, two, and three I
think standalone in the sense
that they're about
responding to incidents.
If there's an issue,
did we breach our SLA?
If there's a problem,
what was the impact to the customer?
Level four is different.
Level four is where you just
go deep diving into your data
to find stuff out like we just did.
So I I we said before,
this is just a background
hum error that's happening.
There's no major outage, there
was no spike or anything.
We just started investigating stuff
and this is this, the
power of DataPrime here is
that we can enrich it
and decorate it with enough information
to produce a business impacting insight.
Really, really important.
So the business insights there is
about basically turning
this disparate collection
of technical signals into
something that anything can use.
And I, before I mentioned
there was two reasons why.
So I talked about maturity
model when you're getting
to this point, is any of you
looking at like AI agents
or anything like that around
your telemetry right now?
Any hands? Yeah, so it's cool
we're getting there slowly.
Yeah.
So one of the most important things
when you're using like any kind
of agent interface with your
telemetry, there's a lot
of telemetry and your agent
has a limited context window.
There's only so much you
can look at at one time.
Well organized data means
that your agent can decide,
make decisions about
which part to look at.
So we have Olly, for example,
which is our observability agent.
It knows how to query
logs, metrics and traces
or do full root cause analysis.
When you organize your data
into things like data sets,
as I mentioned, it knows
where to look, it knows to go
and look at data sets or it knows to go
and look at certain fields and so on.
And by organizing your data,
your AI tools actually have an easier time
of making this analysis.
That's really, really important.
And people often think
that like organized data is
for people and all, it's not,
it's for anything that
needs to communicate it.
We, we don't often spend
time organizing our telemetry
and I think it's, it's
often seen as not necessary,
but when we do it, we get
so many benefits from it
and it's really, really significant.
So we've mentioned that level
one, level two about coverage
and engineering insight and level three
and four are about putting
that engineering insight
into the context of your business.
For those of you who don't
know, our company goal,
our mission is to help
companies make better decisions.
That's right at the top of this thing.
Now if if you wanna start this journey
with your observability data,
you need a platform that
has the necessary features.
There's a reason why we're,
a lot of the industry is
coalescing around things like APM
and Rome, security monitoring,
infrastructure monitoring
log analytics and so on.
You need a platform that
has all these things,
otherwise it's very
difficult to get ahead.
It's very difficult to make progress.
The first half of that maturity model is
mostly about the data.
In fact, I'll show you.
All of this, if you look here,
it's kind of mostly about the data
and getting it into okay shape.
And the second half of this maturity model
is about practices and processes.
So it's about mature
data and mature teams.
I was, years and years ago I was working
at a betting company
and I discovered through
just messing around with some
of the logs that we were
losing money at two racetracks.
And I remember sitting back
and going, cool, and I got on with coding.
I didn't do anything with it.
And I spoke to a lot
of people at the time and
a lot of people had similar
experiences where they found something
but they were like, well that's not
really my thing, whatever.
So if someone had come to me
and said, Hey, you should take
this to the betting manager
or to a certain part of the company,
that's really important.
That would've been a big
thing for the company.
Six weeks later the
product manager came to me
and said, Hey, did you know we're losing
money at these two racetracks?
I was like, oh, never heard of it.
So it's a remarkable thing.
When you, the reason why we do
our engagement the way we do,
the reason why the DevRel team, my team,
engage with customers
is the way they do it is
because so many teams just need
that extra little lift to move forward.
We find that momentum in these
companies is so important
and the way you do that
is things like hackathons,
fun engagements that are just there
to strengthen the relationship
with the customer,
but also give the teams
the effective ability
to make the best use of the platform.
Observability is such a niche space.
I think we forget that sometimes,
especially for any of us who are fans.
And so, 'cause we think about
it all the time, we forget
that most people are thinking
about things like server
uptime and they just wanna
keep the thing running.
So we, when we get ourselves
into this space, we have
to remember that education is a
fundamental part of observability.
And this kind of strategy
is only gonna be powered
by education and engagement in that way.
That's the reason why the
DevRel team, a core part of
how we are measured is the number
of engagements we have with customers.
The number and the creativity
and the timeliness of
those engagements as well.
So it's all well
and good me saying this, how
mature teams mature data driven
by a great platform accelerated
by artificial intelligence will get you
to better decision making.
But it's already happening
in a lot of customers.
So trade web for example,
sending us 130 terabytes
of data a day, they had a
business problem, which was
that they, their audit process
was taking a very long time
and because they had a rehydration
model on that telemetry.
So as I mentioned before, the
data comes in, they hold it
for a couple of weeks
and then they compress it
and they put it into somewhere else.
And what we did was we said, well
the data prem query engine
allows you to query your data
as often as you like at no
additional cost with data
that's held in cloud object
storage in your account.
S3 for the AWS context.
What does that mean?
You can do audit queries in
seconds, not in two weeks,
two week turnaround times.
That's a business problem.
When when I go to people
and say, what does an great
observability stack do for you?
People talk about APM
and service visibility.
I don't think anybody has said to me,
it would be great if it could
help with my audit problems.
It's pretty rare, but it happens
and it's significant, meaningful.
Soft2Bet.
Another example, this slide
says they're growing really fast.
This slide says they're
sending 65 terabytes.
We're actually sending more like
140 terabytes to us right now.
Full stack logs, metrics and traces.
A really, really interesting
use case where we, we started
with focusing on things like mean times
to acknowledge, mean times to recovery.
But actually we got really
wrapped up in the adoption side
of things because we just be,
we saw there was this groundswell momentum
within the company, very
big company distributed.
And so 90% of all the
dashboards being used today,
our Coralogix dashboards that
includes business people,
that's 90% of the company are
using Coralogix dashboards.
And what does that mean?
That means the same insight are
being shared across the entire company
because they have a shared platform.
Really, really important.
And of course it's always nice
to have your meantime
to acknowledge halved
and your meantime to
recovery reduced by 30%.
It's always a nice added bonus.
And we actually help
their teams move faster.
I dunno if anyone's like
familiar with the gaming space
or anything, but it's brutally competitive
and it changes so, so fast.
Teams that are able to
release software faster are a
differentiator as a fundamental
differentiator in that industry.
Kaltura, this was a fun one.
So we onboarded with them,
we took a look at their OTel config
and we said, Hey, this is inefficient.
We didn't have to, it would've
worked, it would've been fine.
We would've got it working.
It made no difference
to how Coralogix worked.
And we spent a few days with
them just rewriting their OTel
config and it saved them 25%
of their telemetry infrastructure.
They're sending us 14 terabytes
of data that's about to go up.
So 14 terabytes of
of data processing architecture
is actually a reasonably
significant amount of money
that they just saved just
by working with OTel.
Just because we figured
we're at level one.
We have to get this right
because this is a foundation
for all the way through level four.
If we were only thinking about level one
and two, we might just, it's fine,
it's a bit janky, it'll work.
But we knew we weren't
where we wanna get to.
We knew what the north star vision is
and we know it needs to
be really squeaky clean
at the start,
otherwise it's gonna be
very difficult to get there.
And they had a five nines uptime
target, which is, is hard.
That's five nines is I think
AWS is four nines, right?
So it's like, it's pretty intense.
And yeah, 25% reduction,
all the infras spend,
that's fin ops right there.
So what does all this mean?
What can we take from all this?
What we're doing at Coralogix
is we're taking a typical
model of engagement, which is
we help you solve problems as they arise.
And we're saying, okay,
we're gonna partner with you.
Find out what, not just
your technical goals are,
but your business goals
and how can we turn an
observability platform from a dev
tool basically to something
that spans your entire company
and has a massive impact across everybody.
And we're gonna do it with
the same kinds of things
that power great dev tools, great APM,
great real user monitoring,
great sim, great AI based query,
great AI agentic experience
in the forms of Olly.
These things impact across
our entire business.
And that the direction of travel is very
clear in that regard.
Notice every single observability vendor,
they're all talking about
things like intelligence,
not talking about a few years
ago it was like catch bugs,
and now it's not that anymore.
It's now it's about business
intelligence, now it's about
finding problems before they happen
and not just in that context,
but constantly, constantly
improving even when there are no problems.
So we're moving past the point
of, let's say, responding
to issues and we're even
moving past the point
of being proactive and catching
issues before they come up.
Now we're just going mining for stuff.
The data is there, the insights are there.
It just needs a bit of massaging
and a platform that can
do all that in one place.
Coralogix has been built
for this exact problem
from day one.
The architecture, everything
has been the same since 2019.
We started thinking about
this stuff a long time ago
and through thousands of
interactions with thousands
of customers, this is the north
star vision we've produced.
Thank you very much for
your time today guys.
I really appreciate it.
I'm gonna hang around some
questions if you're interested,
but I really appreciate the time today
and as the slide says, thank you.
Cheers guys.
(audience applauding)